okay you're giving a right triangle like
this and you have two of the sides of
the right triangle and you want to find
this third side that's when the
Pythagorean theorem comes in so a quick
refresher here when you have a right
triangle you have these two sides that
make up the right angle these are called
the legs or the sides and the side
that's across from the right angle that
longest side is called the hypotenuse
and the Pythagorean theorem tells us
that a squared meaning this leg squared
plus b squared this leg squared is equal
to C squared hypotenuse squared so what
you can think about geometrically is if
you were to make this into a square and
find this area and then make this into a
square and find the area add those two
areas together it's going to equal the
area of this third square which is the
hypotenuse squared so let me show you
how this works with this first example
so you can see that this side here is
going to be a this side here is going to
be B and the one that's across from the
right angle that side is going to be C
so if we go ahead and substitute into
our Pythagorean theorem here we have a
squared which is 3 squared plus B
squared which is 4 squared equals C
squared which in this case we just call
X so x squared so just simplify 3
squared means 3 times 3 9 4 squared is 4
times 4 16 and then if we add these
together we get 25 equals x squared to
get X by itself we're going to take the
square root of both sides and we get 5
so now we know the length of this
hypotenuse let me show you another
example where you're solving for the leg
now sometimes this confuses students so
say for example number 2 again you want
to make sure that you get the a B and C
correctly so remember that a and the B
are the two sides that make up the right
angle and it doesn't matter whether you
call this side a or this side a or this
side B or this side B but the important
thing is that the one across from the
right angle that's your C side so now
we've got x squared plus 12 squared
equals 13 squared 12 squared is 144 13
squared is 169 so 13 times 13 and then
now we just want to get x squared by
itself so let's subtract 144 from both
sides of the equation you can see we're
getting 20
five and then now if we take the square
root of both sides we're getting five so
that's going to be this missing leg here
now sometimes when you're doing these
problems you're going to get a square
root that you can't simplify and you
have to simplify that radical so to
learn more about how to do that check
out the video I did right there and I'll
show you how to simplify those radicals